if you're someone who's chasing uh that
social status
that to feel good about yourself think
about how social media then
plays into our evolutionary
predilections so i'm chasing this high
of like approval from other people and
i'm chasing like yeah i'm working out
i'm getting fit and i'm doing all this
and then i'm able to post a shirtless
picture of me
on instagram that then gets a thousand
likes and you can see how it's like this
is all just a big reward
seeking social status seeking pride like
that's why social media has totally i
don't mean this in a in like a bad way
but you can see that social media has
hijacked that or like used it to their
advantage
i'm joined by matthew kobach matthew
welcome to the show
thank you super excited to be here
pleasure to have you on
man that facial hair is absolutely
crushing it's making me wistful for my
old mustache which is now gone
if people are listening to this i do
have a mustache it's been
four months since i've had to see
anybody so i decided in that four months
to grow a mustache because
really to see if i could like that it's
a challenge to myself and it turns out i
can
every guy that i know who's had latent
mustache desire for the last few years
of their life
has been like yes this is the
opportunity i've been looking for a
global pandemic when i don't have to see
anyone yeah let's grow some ridiculous
facial hair
it's the pandemic has been bad for a lot
of people but great for mustaches
i think the stock price of mustaches
anyone that was long mustaches in
february time
what a return they've seen they've seen
hacker returns that's for sure
sure man so um talk us through give us a
bit of background to you what do you do
what have you
what do you what do you do yeah so if
anyone happens to know who i am it's
solely because of twitter
so uh over the past maybe 14 15 16
months
i've built up a bit of a persona on
twitter just by regularly tweeting just
by putting out stuff
uh really every day i i make it a goal
myself to do it once a day
social media rewards consistency so
literally
however long ago it was i made a pact
with myself that
i was going to take everything i knew
about social media and apply it to my
own personal profile
and just see what happens and it just it
caught fire to be honest you know it's a
little bit of luck a little bit of
knowing what i'm doing and over the past
16 months it's gone from like a thousand
to
you know 65 000 whatever it might be and
and it was because i i work
professionally in social media so i've
been doing this for
over 10 years and i know what kind of
works at least know what works for
brands and i
kind of decided why don't i take that
same concept apply it to my own personal
profile and not do it in a way that's
deceiving or that i'm not being
true to what i think or or who i am but
just like
let's write tweets in a way that i know
works let's talk about things that i
know people are interested in
and it and it took off it you know here
we are
now i'm on your podcast guys exactly
so i find it really interesting i've got
a number of buddies that work in the
social media world
and there does seem to be two very
distinct types especially as you get
higher up there's one type that steve
bartlett
from uh a company social chain in the uk
which my buddy works at
um who exactly as you said takes the
principles applies them to his own
then there's his business partner don
mcgregor also a good buddy of mine past
modern wisdom guest twice
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about social
media
he's like that's work this is home i'm
i'm going to draw a line in the sand
uh so it's interesting to see what
happened so what what were the
principles you said that you were
consistent
um targeted uh messages what else did
you do
so one one key thing that i think a lot
of people leave out is that
they're not focused enough on social
media so you know like we're
all complicated interesting people that
have you know i might
like to go kayaking and then i might
like to think about philosophy and then
i might like to pet my dog and you want
to share all those things in your social
media
the problem is when you're on social
media you're more like a tv channel
you know you're more like espn where
you've got to kind of stick to one
programming if you want people to follow
you
so you really have to narrow in what it
is that you talk about
so even using you for an example you've
already you've got it's the same idea
with your
podcast if all of a sudden you started
had a guest on tomorrow that wanted to
talk about qriket
people are gonna be like well why is
this episode on modern wisdom
um so really you just use that same
concept and apply it to social media and
apply it to your personal brand
and that's how you start uh getting a
following and getting people interested
in what you have to say and building a
community i mean you absolutely have a
community
around your podcast and social media
works the same way
what were you talking about then what
have you been tweeting about for the
last
18 months yeah so a lot of it was about
social media
um just kind of about content in general
about the stuff that works and the stuff
that doesn't work
social media was interesting because it
came up
you know what 2004 i guess is when
facebook started and
when it first kind of got big when it
was clear that brands were going to be
using it
there was like a land grab by by people
that were just kind of
thrown out like do this to grow your
following and do this to get engagement
and that kind of worked in social media
1.0
but now we're to a point where that
stuff doesn't work anymore either the
algorithms have changed
or they have uh you know there's new
platforms that you just can't game the
system that way
and so i just started tweeting
matter-of-factly which again works you'd
be direct be concise
about stuff that works and stuff that
doesn't work and
i think people found it somewhat
refreshing you know it wasn't
if you follow social media stuff on on
social media
you get a lot of like just be authentic
or you know social media is meant to be
social
it's been repeated so many times it just
doesn't mean anything like that's not
helpful to someone who's trying to get
better at it
so i would literally do things like if
you're on instagram you're going to post
a photo that's this size
if you're on twitter you've got to you
know tweet every day or you've got to be
consistent you got to narrow in
your focus and it was the stuff that
these people kind of that work in the
industry knew to be true
you know it's like they felt it and
that's what's key to getting retweets
it's this thing that like you kind of
feel in yourself that
that you just haven't articulated
yourself and then when you see someone
else articulate it
they've now spoken for you and they're
likely to retweet it
and so that's as simple as it was if you
can tap in
to what someone else is thinking and do
their you know
put it on paper like that's how you you
get people that are like i like the way
this person thinks because i think like
i think
and and that's really what i did and uh
and then on top of it
i just happened to be interested this is
actually how i found your podcast i
happen to be interested in
philosophy and happiness and you know
making my life as enjoyable as possible
and uh i feel like you probably there'll
be some overlap with
with your interest as well uh you look
for like this really really old advice
that has stood the test of time like i
don't want someone's advice from five
years ago
i want someone's advice from 2000 years
ago that's still relevant today
and so i just started taking that i mean
like stoicism kind of stuff like you can
apply it to social media
and so that's all i would do i would
take this like philosophical lens
just took it and look at content and the
so many of my tweets i swear to god
if you take out the word social media in
the tweet replace it with life
i've just plagiarized it from someone
who wrote it 2 000 years ago
but it just resonates people underst
these these beautiful concepts that
people get
and you could literally do with anything
you could take out social media put it
in motorcycle repair put it in canoeing
put it in friendship
uh it's like the like that a lot of the
big problems we've had in life people
been thinking about for a lot
a lot of years so use their wisdom and
apply it to the problems we're facing
today
i wonder if seneca knew 2 000 years ago
that he would be providing you
with content in a couple of millennia
there's some guys going to remove some
of the words from this put social media
in
and get a thousand retweets
i i would love to thank him if i had the
chance there's no way he ever
could conceive of that but like if you
really think about twitter too it's no
different than that kind of philosophy
uh
like that's why i love twitter so much
is uh they're these ways to spout out
wisdom
to uh to be pithy to to kind of say
these things that like
uh the reason i like pithy sayings and
the reason i like twitter
is because there's a way that you can
say certain things and it just
hits you you know uh and it's different
than a long-form conversation like this
which is
equally as valuable not saying it isn't
but there's ways that you can say
certain things that it just hits someone
right in the soul or right in the heart
and uh you know if only for a second you
can kind of change their thinking or
kind of shakes them out
of their day-to-day stuff and and i
think that's what a lot of ancient
wisdom does
and so i'm just kind of taking it
sometimes i don't even get rid of the
word life i just keep it in
uh and other times i apply to social
media yeah
you're very very correct about what you
say
that um small aphorisms
can really make a big impact because a
large concept
ends up being distilled down to probably
one sentence description
and perfect example of that i know that
we're both fans of the moral animal by
robert wright and i was reading it this
morning
and there was a sentence that stuck out
to me
uh right in the middle of the book it's
like 60 of the way through
and it's the sentence which to me
describes what most of the book is about
and it says gin our genes did not design
us to be happy they designed us to be
effective
and i'm like that's just some throwaway
line
in the middle of this huge like
multi-hundred page book
i remember the sentence and the sentence
is
a distillation of the concept of the
book
yeah and that's honestly how i go about
tweeting
is i read books like that i read stuff
just because that happens to be my hobby
it works out
and you get beautiful lines like that
you get
or you're just able to think about it
and and summarize it yourself
and that's what kind of goes through
like you see the you read lines like
that and it hits you so hard that like
uh and i could go off on on that for a
while like i love evolutionary
psychology i'm a
full you know if you want to call it a
cult i'm in the evolutionary psychology
cult
i've been i've been uh i did a
dissertation
started writing it and that was my
theoretical framework was evolutionary
psychology
and uh and i i've sidetracked myself now
because you're talking let's go down
let's go down let's let's down let's do
it
let's do it man i'll tell you what
before we go into that who do you think
is the best aphorist on the planet
oh man probably probably neval oh man i
know
i know i don't don't want to give the
obvious answer
but how about this how about there is
i'll get i'll give one that maybe some
people don't know
there is someone called orange book on
twitter okay so it's orange book
i think underscore so one word orange
book underscore
uh brilliant a lot a lot of that same
stuff but a lot about just how to live a
better life
um how to be happier and just writes it
in a way
like what i think a lot of people miss
about twitter or don't understand about
twitter is you can have these ideas but
you also then have to get them on paper
you have to write them in a way that's
easy to read and uh this person is
anonymous or pseudonymous
and so i don't know who he is or she is
but uh
the way that they write the way that
they think is just super clear super
concise and it's
it's one of those people that adds so
much value to your timeline if you're a
regular twitter user
i know that's why naval as a guy who
doesn't follow anyone and just tweets
like single words sometimes or like
couple of word sentences
has like nearly amassed like nearly a
million followers now
and you're right as much as i don't want
it to be the obvious answer
it is for a reason now that there's a
reason that floyd mayweather was the
best boxer on the planet for a while you
don't want to say that he is the best
defensive boxer of all time
but he was and naval right naval's the
floyd mayweather of aphorisms man with a
little bit more humble yeah he is
and i would say a healthy more dose of
humbleness if we're comparing him to
floyd mayweather uh but like and even
naval aside like you can
see the reason someone like him is so
popular and you can people can mimic
this and it's certainly just a style of
writing
but it's the fact that there's this
sense that so much wisdom is packed into
just such a tight concise
uh package that that's what makes it so
interesting and makes it uh so relatable
and so easy to understand
it's almost like you know the like a
picture is worth a thousand words
you can have tweets that are ten words
but they feel like a thousand words and
that's how he tweets and that's
some of these uh people that are so
popular like they tweet the same way and
it's that same idea of the
of the moral animal uh summarization you
gave in one sentence
you understand how we're designed we're
not designed to be happy
we're not even necessarily designed to
to reproduce we're designed to reproduce
specific genes so you got a gene
that doesn't care if it's like if it's
doing something good or bad it's just
like
will this gene multiply next time like
will it be around and like that's all it
really
boils down to and uh and i'll go down
this rabbit hole just for a second
that's why i love thinking about
evolutionary psychology is once you know
how we're programmed
you can think how do we how do we
communicate how do we relate to people
how do if i'm a brand how do i sell
stuff how do i get people excited how do
i
kind of make a cult following out of
this brand that i'm representing
and whether it or it's yourself uh
there's just so many
things to understand about human nature
that you can then look at and apply it
to any part of your life and i just
happen to be
in marketing happen to be in social
media but you could use it in sales you
could use it in presentations you could
use it in podcasts like
it's just it applies literally
everything that's why i think it's just
such a beautiful theory to
to just have in the back of your head
and have dancing around there at all
times
yeah relationships family life
and friendships everything um
i genuinely believe that evolutionary
psychology is the ultimate red pill
it stops you from seeing matrix and
starts you seeing code
but it does it in a way that means that
i don't know whether you found this when
i started reading it i started slowing
down a lot i became less effective in
the real world
because i was triple quadruple checking
everything that i'm like oh so why do
you think that what does it say about me
that i'm asking myself why did you say
that
what does it say about me that i'm
asking what did you what does it say
about me and you just end up this like
constant regression all the way back you
know what i mean
oh absolutely that's what one one
concept i've been kind of playing with
and i'm real bad at it and it's
super like it's super like down the
rabbit whole kind of thing
but it's a sense of like identity like
who are you what do you think
and if you can lose your own sense of
identity if you can just say like i'm
just
another person in this big blue planet
whatever
uh it's easier to understand your own
thinking so like you like you going down
like why did i say that well he
responded to this and i said that
and that and you realize like that's
kind of how you're hardwired but we have
such an ego you want to defend
everything you said you want to defend
everything you think
but as soon as you if you can just take
a step back and think you know what this
uh this is just some person
doing something let me try to
disassociate with what that person did
even though it's yourself
and that's how you can better understand
all the stuff and hopefully make better
decisions
now it's next to impossible it's really
hard and i'm not good at it by any means
i'm you know i've got an ego i've got i
take things personally all the time
but the best thing you can do like if
you're ever in an argument and you can
just like
take a step back and think like these
are just two people who are aren't
communicating properly
you can then all of a sudden be a lot
more logical and see the other person's
point of view
so much quicker than if you go that
person hurt my feelings and they did
something wrong and now i'm mad and i'm
upset
about it but again word word animals
that are designed to have emotional
reactions so it takes a lot of practice
to do that it takes a lot of practice to
see uh like how we're programmed it
takes a lot of practice to see that like
i'm reacting like this because at some
point it benefited my ancestors to react
like this
and i've got to be a smarter person i
you know like i've got we've got the
uh frontal lobe capacity to realize that
just because we're programmed this way
doesn't mean we have to act this way it
means we're likely to act this way it
means that we want to act this way but
it doesn't mean that we have to act this
way
it's all well and good saying
this is my gene expressing itself
through feelings
but when you get sadness happiness anger
any
emotion it feels it it's not as logical
as that right it is a sensation
it is the expression of that gene giving
you a sensation in yourself
that causes you to act in a particular
way if you haven't been around people
for a while and you start to get lonely
that yearning for people is to get
yourself back to the tribe
but it just feels like loneliness it
feels like some
curse bestowed from the gods or on the
positive side some sort of blessing
that's been handed to you
you know that feeling after you complete
a workout you don't think oh
that was me expanding my domain of
competence and
you know like it's not that's not what
you think but that is what's happening
and learning that slowly as robert
wright continues to
deep throat me with this evolutionary
psychology red pill
um there's a hell of a metaphor there
we don't have these in this state hey
look you get a little bit of colorful
language it is our language
we'll anglicize what we want we'll spell
everything with an s we'll add
use into like every word that we can
uh and we'll talk about robert wright
deep throat
yeah a red pill yeah
um i i just love this one one thing too
is it's
it is so hard to be in the throes of it
to be feeling something emotional and to
take that step back
and what really helps me is i'm very
lucky i have
a fiance and we're really good at kind
of holding each other accountable when
something like that happens
and it literally happened today i moved
out in new york
i had to ship a bunch of packages and
for no reason the mail just returned
them back to a place that we don't live
anymore
and i got super frustrated got a little
stressed out like how are we gonna get
this
and um you know like that's your you
know that's your body like in
fight or flight but there's literally
nothing i can do about her right now so
you know she's like relax like take a
breath like there's no
like we can't solve this right now we're
gonna have to figure out a solution like
we'll
get a friend to come over and do it but
like literally stressing about it right
now
does you no good it's just gonna make
you more unhappy um and i was getting
ready for this she's like
like she didn't say this but this is
what i internalize it's like do i really
want to be stressed out
for this podcast that i'm excited to go
on for this person that i'm eager to
talk to
and you can see so many issues in
people's lives
where they kind of let these little
stressful things build up and then you
come out and explode
or that you're not your best possible
version of yourself and you're having a
conversation like this and you're not
expressing what you actually think and
you're not
having a rational train of thought or
rational mind so it's so important to be
able to do that and then to surround
yourself with people
who think the same way and that's really
what i'm trying to do going forward is
who who who thinks the same way that i
do who can reel me in because i'm not
perfect at it by any means
um and then who are the people that
don't do that that don't control their
emotions that do
go and stress about things and bring you
down um you know take a step away from
those people and take a step closer to
the people that
that understand this and want to get
better at it you the external
accountability is such
such an assistance man like it's such an
unfair advantage
i've been thinking about this a lot i'll
be interested to hear your thoughts on
this so
this is very trite to say if you want to
go fast go alone if you want to go far
go together
i'm aware that that's like off the back
of a bumper sticker somewhere
um but yeah yeah um that's the perfect
it's a perfect wait hey look
1000 retweets um but
i've been thinking about that an awful
awful lot about where the
optimal line is for solitude
versus relying on others um and as
someone who's 32 and still single
it's interesting for me to see the pace
at which my buddies are
moving and i think that there's been
i've had a disproportionate advantage
up to now but i'm now
starting to see that situations that
perhaps might be diffused
by a partner or by um
like having a family having dog having
kids whatever it might be
that distraction is actually now the
tables are starting to turn
does that make sense like the literally
i'm watching that go fast
in the beginning like tortoise versus
hair situation play out in front of my
eyes
it's funny i think this goes back to
concept you've talked to you about rory
sutherland
right and one of his things like the
opposite of a good idea is sometimes
another good idea you know
and it's that same kind of concept it's
like the opposite of going fast can also
like the opposite of like having success
by going fast and also be
having success by going slow and i think
some of these it's like
it depends on what stage you are in your
life it depends what you want to
accomplish
and so i can certainly see a scenario
where you're alone and you're able to
spend time and you'll be able to like
kind of get
your head right that you can't do with
someone else well you just mentioned
before we go
you mentioned before we got started that
the mustache is going because you've got
to go to a wedding
like there's 50 percent 50 of the
weddings that you need to go to
are your partners friends and 50 of them
are your friends
so if i don't have to go to the wedding
i do 50 for your weddings and everyone
else that's a competitive advantage
like you cannot get out even naval
ravikant
can't get out of going to his wife's
friend's wedding
like it ain't happening you know and so
that there's a perfect example
i well right and it ends up being uh a
trade-off
obviously and so you get to it and but a
lot of it too is you end up if you can
in solitude if you can won your single
one you're in your 20s and 30s depending
on when you get married and settle down
which by the way i'm
slightly older than you but i was in the
same thing at 32 i was single
um like spending time with myself like i
had a dog like we would go to the dog
park every day i'd walk a trail for an
hour
and um you know sometimes taking a
notebook and
there's help for you yeah but no but
it's like i was in the exact same shoes
and
and honestly doing this like you're
obviously in a situation where you're
setting yourself
up to succeed not only right now but
later like talking to all these
interesting people
not that i'm interesting but all the
other people that you've had on before
but talking to them
and like getting all these different
perspectives on lines like you got a lot
of good stuff
like bouncing around in your head even
if you don't uh
you know like write it down or repeat it
or something it's still in there it's
still
processing and so whenever it is that
you
you know settle down start a family
whatever it is you've already got such a
good foundation
that it's going to end up being it's
it's kind of like you've put up all the
all the bricks of the house and you're
like all right there's literally no more
bricks i can put up like i guess i could
add some more bricks but it's not going
to make the house any better
it's time to add some drywall it's time
to add some paint and some furniture and
stuff
and that's where you get to a point
where someone else is able to help you
uh add those things
um nice analogy i love it i had a and
andrew scott was on the show the other
day
uh longevity expert he said more women
in 2019
had children over the age of 40 than
under the age of 20.
oh wow yeah i i'm serious
you have to kind of believe that too
because i think there is a lot of people
that are kind of doing what we're doing
where you want to get yourself right
first
you want to make sure that like you're
the best possible version or at least
you're on the right
track and uh and obviously if you have
to have the means to do it and stuff but
i
i like i'm in the same boat i'm not
rushing to have kids i want to be i want
to have everything
feel secure feel right and and feel like
i'm ready for this next step as opposed
to just being thrown into the fire and
like
hope for the best kiddo i know i know
yeah just jumping at the deep end
tell me about the stock exchange tell
the people that don't know what you did
for the last
last few years what what you did
so i was the head of social media and
digital media for the new york stock
exchange
recently left that job uh just a few
weeks ago
and what i did was they didn't have a
social media
uh presence really before i came this is
2014.
and so i had to create it i had to uh
figure out what we're going to do figure
out what platforms were going to be on
and it was so much fun i was very lucky
to
be in a company to have a boss that just
was kind of like all right
if you think it's a good idea do it
which is unbelievably empowering for any
job like this is outside of social media
if you have a boss that trusts you
but especially in social media where
it's so public facing
you know like i mess up cnbc reports
like it's like that's a that's a lot of
stress especially the first time
and i know every person who's ever done
social media for a brand it's kind of
like that first tweet that first post
it's like being on top of a cliff and
like you're looking over yeah oh for
sure and you're like looking over the
edge you're like all right i gotta jump
i gotta jump in here
and you just kind of gotta psych
yourself up to do it obviously you do it
a thousand times it
it becomes you know second nature but to
know that like if you mess up
you're gonna trend for the wrong reasons
and there's gonna be uh reporters
calling
especially for an institution like the
new york stock exchange like you can
imagine one wrong tweet
and you know like you could arguably
move the markets with the wrong tweet or
someone had ill intentions oh my god
they're taking away all the past from me
now that i'm gone
not me but so anyway so i did that and
uh and what happened was
the no one really expected the new york
stock exchange to be any good at social
media
uh so the which is good news for me
because that means the bar was set
incredibly low and that's the secret to
life have expectations
super low and then making it so you
can't help but to exceed them
uh it's funny i was actually thinking
about this and again i'm going to go off
on a tangent because that's apparently
just what i do
uh but think about like so much of your
life is comparison
so it's kind of like you if you live in
this really nice subdivision
and it's everyone's got all these
beautiful houses and you've got the
crappiest house in that subdivision
you're gonna kind of feel like you don't
really have that good of a life
but if you live in a less nice
subdivision you have the same exact
house and it just happens to be the
nicest house in that subdivision you're
going to feel like you're a king
and it's because you're comparing
yourself to you know what's around you
and that was the same idea for the new
york soccer chains you're kind of
comparing ourselves to other
financial institutions which were
unbelievably boring unbelievably dry
unbelievably uninteresting and so all it
was was like
what if we just kind of talk like we're
a person what if we put me
on camera interviewing ceos uh and
really quick stuff like you know 60
seconds
where we're able to demystify ceos a
little bit because
uh you know with the elon musks and the
bezos and the zuckerbergs like they
become mythical creatures almost you
know
and so we want to just we wanted to do a
little bit like
ceos are just regular people and it was
and we did it super low five i've got my
phone right here it was literally like
me
grabbing a ceo doing this and just
and just talking to him completely
disarm the ceo
it felt super real it didn't you know
like whatever you're watching a ceo talk
they're hitting their talking points
they're talking to investors they're
you know they're super polished but this
completely disarmed them
and we could have fun little stupid you
know questions that
weren't about the stock price that
weren't about you know the
next quarter so is this really unique
way
to to talk about financial markets to
talk about businesses and to talk to
ceos
and uh and we were just making it up as
we went along you know like a snapchat
was invented or like
gained popularity while i was there and
it was like what are we going to do on
snapchat we should be on it
and that's when it turned into all right
i'll interview ceos like let's
and again that's where it goes back to
having a team that empowers you
i i literally said i'm like are you all
right if i'm on camera
as the face of the new york stock
exchange on social interviewing ceos
and they were like no love it great do
it like we trust you
and so and that's why again bar was set
low had a team that really empowered me
and then we got noticed by like media
outlets and and stuff so people wanted
to write stories people wanted to say
you know like wow we didn't expect the
new york stock exchange pinterest page
to be this good
why why is it this good it's like i mean
yeah i appreciate it it's good but it's
because you expected nothing
so as long as i had and like the like
again
the bar was one i gave you a three out
of ten but
you know three times expectations uh so
that that's what i did for
for um or for five years six years
whatever it was um
and then and then moved on i had a cool
new opportunity and so i jumped into
that
you must have had some awesome
experiences during that time
oh for sure if you go i wish i i wish i
would have taken more pictures like
that's my biggest regret
if you go to my instagram which is the
same as my twitter uh
you can see so many pictures of like so
many cool celebrities and athletes and
ceos and stuff
um it was like a pinch yourself moment
every day um and i i don't mean to say
this right i mean to see that say this
part because like i literally still
can't believe it and still can't quite
comprehend it
i remember i was interviewing shaquille
o'neal for the second time
and i just remember thinking like
nowhere in my life plan
was the sentence ever gonna be i'm about
to go
interview shaq again and it was just so
wild and so crazy so like that
that's why like i'll have so many fond
memories of that place like the
the amount of cool people i i got to
meet like it was just through the roof
and again the fact that i was able to
use social media you have someone super
famous like [ __ ] come he gets hounded
everyone wants to talk with him everyone
wants his picture everyone wants his
autograph
but i legitimately had a business reason
so i can go up to their pr person and i
go hey i know shaq's here and he's
talking about how he just joined the
board of papa john's
um i do social media for the new york
stock exchange i'd love to get
90 seconds with him so that he can
promote the papa john's thing
and they go yeah sure great so they push
everyone away i get to go in
i've got like a whole crowd around me
like talk about like getting real good
by doing something public you've got
like this whole floor of traders and all
these people watching
but again it's just me him and a camera
doing a quick little interview for 90
seconds because
you know he's there to do press and i'm
you know social media's kind of pressed
it's at least publicity
and was able to do stuff like that in a
regular basis it was it was just
you know it's still surreal to be honest
dude that must be so cool
like having memories like that from a
job is worth an
awful awful lot there's some things that
if you're fortunate you can look back on
in your career
and be really really thankful that they
happened and uh it's worth an awful lot
more than the paycheck
when it's like that what's the
atmosphere like in the new york stock
exchange obviously we see these kind of
quite good shade images of the guys with
the
the pieces of paper shouting in the air
like it is it's a kind of alpha male
a gram of caffeine per day atmosphere
kind of
does it permeate through the social
media floor i'm happy
i'm happy you said caffeine yeah
so so a lot of it is done electronically
now
so what you almost have so you don't
really have that you know like you see
it in the movies you see it on tv
it's not quite like that anymore you
still have people there but what they're
doing is facilitating these trades
electronically
so they're just really overseeing stuff
they'll get on the phone for large
trades they'll make sure like they have
a uh
um a phone where they can talk to the
cfo certain companies vice versa so the
cfo can talk to them if they don't like
something that's going on with the stock
or they have a question
um but yeah it ends up being a lot more
quiet it's a lot more like beeping
and buzzing from the computers than
people expect
the uh the one exception or the i
shouldn't say the one exception but the
biggest exception is during the ipo time
and that's when an ipo is when a company
goes from private to public
so you've got someone like airbnb who's
private right now at some point they're
going to go public
and when they do they have to pick an
exchange to go public on and
what that means when they go public is
someone like me and you can buy shares
like me and you can't buy shares in
airbnb now but when they're public
that's when you can just you know open
your robinhood account whatever it might
be
by airbnb uh but what they've got to do
is you've got this private market that
has a bunch of shares then you have the
public market that wants to buy shares
so they're pricing they're trying to
figure out the right price to open the
stock at
at what price like what does the public
want this stock
at and that's where you have traders who
like in real time
are yelling at each other wanting to
know what like the current like people
what are people offering what are people
offering to sell it at what are people
offering to buy it at
uh so that's super exciting and that
stuff like and again i got to be in like
the middle of that
like that's wild to me and and i had
plenty of traders i'm sure if there's
any trader listening to this they're
thinking ah
that sob matt kobach he got in my way so
does he have many times a picture of the
video because
you're a little bit like a photographer
if you've ever had like a photographer
at a sporting event
you have to get up close you have to be
unapologetic about getting in someone's
way and getting the shot
and it's the same way with social media
uh you know like they didn't want
you know our audience didn't want the
shot where like i'm shooting this way
and it's
20 feet away but trader they wanted the
phone right in their face so i could see
someone yelling and doing that
and like again that's what sells our
floor that's what sells our product too
so it was justifiable that i was that
close
but then they also have a job so you
know you kind of have these competing
things and you get to a good rhythm of
they know who i am i know who they are
we try to stay out of each other's way
uh but super exciting just
being in the middle of that like there's
so many ipo pictures you have all these
major companies that have ipo for the
past five years
and you've got like getty and uh you
know the stock
photos of it and i'm sitting there like
i'm just next to the ceo just hanging
out
sadly very embarrassingly if you're on
the podcast you can't see this but i'm
gonna like i'm just sitting there
looking at my phone like this like uh
like i don't doing work yeah exactly i
swear i'm working but they look like i'm
just scrolling instagram or something
texting so what are you having for
dinner honey uh really i really don't
want italian again the last time that we
got that
snap you and basis
and then you've got like traders in the
background like yeah speaking of
one of the we had snap go public there
which is awesome you have evan spiegel
and then his
uh i forget if his wife or girlfriend at
the time but miranda kerr they're
they're taking like
snapchat selfies with like the dog
filter on their face it's like it's just
super
again surreal moment like this is the
snapchat
with his wife putting on the dog filter
with the tongue on the floor
of the stock exchange like it's just you
know where i work
yeah i'm just at work why did i quit
what am i doing i know man
um have you checked out the r wall
street bets reddit
sub thread
so these guys are the most outlandish
traders on the internet they made it to
the front page
of some huge
financial magazine at the beginning of
this year
um there's been all sorts of ongoing
crazy litigation to do it it's like a
million plus people now
but basically it's it's people that are
beyond reckless on robin hood like
insane
calls and puts and within with
ridiculous time frames like by the end
of tomorrow
and there's people leveraging their
entire net worth
and more for internet points from people
that they're never going to meet
and they get immortalized on this
like within this sub community and
there's some
people that have made hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in a couple of days and then blown the
entire amount and
now like 300 grand in debt and it's
just the most there's a the dankest
trades of wall street bets is a youtube
series
um which like summarizes each quarter's
trades
and goes back through it man it is it's
intense you will
you will be on it
these people don't know what the f
they're doing like
like yeah i know it's the point oh it's
so oh it's like
oh my god i'll i'll try i'll it can only
look for so long
yeah like i feel the it i think it
brings
i just it's it's have you seen it you've
seen those videos of the guys that do
they'll climb up a crane tower that's
sort of 500 feet in yeah
that's precisely the same feeling that
you have when you watch wall street bets
on reddit
oh my god oh i just hope these i hope
they're not kids but they are kids and i
hope they're responsible
i know i need i need someone to be like
matt you need to
you need to stop thinking about this
you're stressing yourself exactly we're
talking about being mindful and
reverting to the present earlier on it's
what's funny too is working at the stock
exchange so many people ask me like give
me stock tips give me advice and my
advice is so unbelievably boring
it's like find a nice diversified etf
just put your money in it every month
and don't touch it for 10 years like
that's what you do
and uh but everyone wants to you know
what's the stop shock of this year yeah
exactly
no dude you're the guy that's been stood
on the
the ground floor at the new york stock
exchange for the last
six years and morgan housel is as far as
i'm concerned one of the best sort of
financial writers
on the internet and both of you said the
same thing
just find something aggregated that's
not going to tank
and don't touch your money and hold on
and when it goes low hold on harder
and then keep holding on and then maybe
in a generation or two's time you'll
have some money
that's it and it's so boring it's so
boring someone
what they wanted to say is that at the
beginning of february you should have
decided to go long
on tesla because now it's at four x yeah
can you and like who would no one in the
right mind would even said that
you know like that's the problem too is
like you wanna do um
you know someone wants like a stock tip
like what you're doing it's like you're
literally asking someone to predict the
future and to predict emotion
like the you can it's really hard to
argue some stocks i won't name any by
name
but they don't necessarily trade on
fundamentals they don't trade on stuff
that anyone can see they trade because
people love the brand or love the
company just love the idea
and i don't know how to gauge that i
don't know how to predict that i don't
know how to say
people love this stock and they're going
to keep buying it like maybe maybe not i
really don't know but
you know it's not like oh i know this
new chip manufacturer
just uh cut their you know they got a
new they got a new plant in whatever
country and it's gonna
cut their prices by half like that's the
only reasonable type of information that
you could use
that would then be like all right and i
don't think it's been priced into the
stock price so that's a good buy
in my opinion but likes it at the past
four months it's just been like mostly
emotion it seems like at least the big
names
so like i don't know what was handling
the social media like
during the last four months so it became
um so one we don't actually talk about
specific stocks that much we don't talk
about
uh stock prices the the reason being is
that like so legally our restrictions
were
you cannot talk about like what a
stock's going to do or what you think
it's going to do
we can't like give financial advice we
got to stay away from that stuff so it
was very black and white about
what we could and couldn't do you could
talk about what a stock is currently
like what it has done like so it closed
today at 70
that was fine you can't say anything
forward-looking that was a big no-no
but what happened was we were a little
uh
like we had some fun you know like if
there was a cool
trend on social media that made sense
for us we would join it
um you know again it was me on camera
like palin around with ceos like it was
showing them in a different light
all of a sudden in what was it february
everything just starts tanking so you're
having like
1000 point drops in the dow and and the
way the stock exchange is set up
if it drops quickly enough or by a
certain percentage in a day
it literally freezes so like you
literally no one can trade for 15
minutes it's like
all right guys what happens when that
happens
is there like a big red alarm bell that
goes somewhere
yeah it's just it's like all of a sudden
nothing happens but all of a sudden it
goes
and it had i don't know that it happened
i'm gonna someone feel free to reply and
tell me the actual answer but it's been
like a decade or two i think since it
happened last
um but all of a sudden everything on the
floor
just like pauses so it's it's uh
and it's a different color you got red
and green and i forget what it was maybe
it was like yellow or something
and it was like just like x's and so
none of the screens you could like trade
and uh and it's an automatic thing it's
it's a
it's a computer program so once the uh
yeah
once it hits i think it was seven
percent once it hits that it's literally
no one can do anything and you just hang
out for 15 minutes and it's real surreal
you've got
everyone on the floor just kind of
waiting for 15 minutes
uh but for us what we wanted to do is we
knew it was going to happen like you can
kind of before a stop
before the market opens you can see what
the futures are trading and you can see
that like the dow is going to open up or
down whatever percent
and so if you see that it's gonna open
down six percent you know like oh
there's a chance that this could
go further so sitting there waiting and
for us what we wanted to do is one that
started happening
one we wanted to be very real time we
wanted people to get their information
from us so if the if the stocks were
paused trading
i was literally sitting there i had the
tweet ready because i knew it was going
to happen
as soon as it did i hit go and the
reason is we then became like the
trusted source
for that information when people were
doing stories about it they saw our
name and so we got to get our brand out
there significantly more than if we
waited even a minute later
uh the other thing we did is now i mean
people are losing money
you know like this is people's 401ks
these are people's investments that
maybe they're living off of or at the
very least now panicked that you know
you bought something and now it's down
20 percent
um so we just we got rid of all you know
kind of cute stuff we got rid of all fun
stuff and it just became very matter of
fact
here's where the market just opened up
here's where the market just closed at
and let's talk to this person about what
this means for you know their stock
so we really changed our tone overnight
almost
uh and so we you know like we're talking
about people's money and if money if
money's doing well you can have some fun
you can be a little silly
but when people are losing money you
know that's when you kind of tighten the
tie and you look a little more
professional
and and you don't have as much fun
anyone that's ever been on a very long
diet
knows exactly the same feeling as when
you've got money worries
it's like everything is everything sucks
everything that happens in your life is
like this thing happened
but i'm hungry and it's the same as that
it's like this thing happened my
daughter just won her football that's
great
but the stock markets just crashed this
thing happened but the stock markets
just crashed so you're right like don't
anyone out there that is listening that
is getting social media advice
if you the guy from the cdc who looks
after their social media
or the the lady who looks after british
rail network or something like that if
everything goes down
don't don't do the tick tock dancing
videos of everyone in the office like
save that for another day
yeah it's also a good lesson too it's
why we don't schedule anything
so a lot of social media managers will
schedule stuff in advance they get a
calendar
it's you know timeless it's evergreen
kind of stuff like it works on a tuesday
as well as it works on a saturday night
but especially on twitter you don't know
what's gonna happen so you don't wanna
like i remember when kobe bryant died
uh all of a sudden like all the tv
stations are breaking to it and this
news we're still figuring out like no
one really knows the information who
does
and then if you're a brand and you're
tweeting like lol ice cream saturday
like you look completely tone deaf you
look like you're not paying attention
and you know you maybe just had
something scheduled on a saturday but
it's
i will never schedule stuff for that
reason especially on twitter because you
just risk looking tone deaf
and you can with all the black lives
matter blackout tuesday precisely yeah
here's our there's just a new sale
like imagine if someone had done like uh
black fridays come this june or
something like that
and it actually happened on that on that
tuesday that could have been a very very
unfortunate situation
a hundred percent uh it's so it's just
not it's just not
worth the risk i know the um person who
heads up comms
and uh social media for john deere the
the tractor company
and every morning they literally take
the temperature of what's going on in
the world
they're like all right what's going on
and they're global companies so they're
looking at different countries they're
looking at different cultures and
they're like all right our job
is to make sure that we're not saying
anything that could now be insensitive
that could now be misconstrued yeah i
mean you've even got it with uh with
covid
let's say you had this like ad campaign
with a bunch of people hugging
you've got to scrap that you can't have
campaigns of people shaking hands or
high-fiving
like all this stuff changes so quickly
that you've got to be really really
nimble to make sure that you're not
um you know coming off insensitive did
you ever take your interest in
evolutionary psychology
and use it when watching the traders and
the atmosphere and the personalities of
the people that you saw
on the new york stock exchange i can't i
so i certainly
applied it to the content we did so
like i i've always so the oh everyone a
little bit i didn't actually explain
what i did a
phd in which by the way i dropped out i
did not finish the phd
a lot of people think i have the phd
because i say i pursued it just to be
100 certain i do not have it i'm a
dropout and i'm a very proud phd dropout
i like to say i was smart enough to be a
phd dropout
nice um what i did was this is in 2008 9
10.
and so social media was like just kind
of getting started and i wanted to
predict how people use social media
so that's why evolutionary psychology
was such a
robust theoretical framework to base
predictions on how people would use
social media so that's when it became
clear
of like how to communicate on social
media how to do it if you're a brand
like what are the kinds of stuff that
people
want to do like they want to build
communities like we're tribal uh
species and so you want to like take
into account like those things like
where
um a species that needs to communicate
clearly to understand each other
and so uh was really invested in there
and so that's what i used evolutionary
psychology from
if i was a traitor myself and i was
doing that
i probably would try to think about it
differently but it was like my world
never
necessitated you know interacting with
them in that fashion it was my job was
to like
show emotion because i understand that
emotion sells the new york stock
exchange
rather than explaining what a market
model was and so that means so for me
the evolutionary
uh psychology aspect was let me get in
this trader's face while he's shouting
and i'm gonna record a video and that's
what's gonna resonate with our audience
as opposed to like
me talking having like an interview with
someone where they're kind of explaining
what they do
um i'm sure there's a whole litany of
things like if i
you know wanted to think about
evolutionary psychology and why people
are nuts about trading certain stocks
and other stocks like
i'm sure there's a totally ripe for
for exploration but i've never i haven't
spent much time thinking about it
how many of your predictions about
social media came through uh well so
what i ended up doing is i was
at the time i was looking at um
uh interpersonal communication and so it
could and to be honest it's been so long
i don't even remember what i ended up
predicting because what ended up
happening
was i would uh and for anyone who's
never done a dissertation this is how it
works at least for mine
as you do a bunch of coursework then you
have to have a
um like a study that you set up you make
some predictions make some hypotheses
and then you've got to test them so i
would write them based on where social
media was
at the current time and then it was
moving so fast
facebook would make an update and then
make my predictions moot because i had
you know i had to work in the like the
they changed their algorithm and now
like what i wanted to do was like well
that's not part of what their platform
is anymore
and so i got really frustrated with that
which is why i left it was like
a year of like writing and rewriting and
rewriting i'm like this is i can't do
this anymore
um but a lot of the predictions i made
was about we're about attraction
and about like uh how to engage with
other people and so
and again i forget exactly what i said
but it was very clear that like online
dating was gonna take off it's very
clear
of what to how to position your profile
to be can be more attractive as
opposed to less attractive uh the
difference is uh what to do in a profile
if you're a male attracting a female and
if you're a female attracting a male
uh and so you and you kind of see all
this stuff now and all the online dating
you know all the tinders
and uh bumbles and stuff of the world so
that was kind of where i was at and then
it was like how do we then communicate
with each other
uh once we've decided you know this is a
person i want to talk to
so it really the the closest thing i can
say to a prediction that came true
was really that we're going to use
social media in the same exact way that
we
you know communicate offline and the
reason tinder was so effective
or so popular the reason it totally
zoomed off is one they gamified it a
little bit they made it fun interesting
but more importantly it wasn't like a
dating site you know what you don't do
if you're single and you go to a bar you
do not get to see
what everyone's interests are it's not
like they're hovering over their head
like i like canoeing and i like going
outdoors
and i'm this old whatever you go to a
bar and you go that person
i'm kind of attracted to that person and
you go over and you strike up a
conversation or neither works or doesn't
work
and that's what tinder was the
difference was instead of
saying like i'm attracted to that person
i'm gonna go walk up to him you just
swiped right
and then it would real it mimicked what
we do offline
and that's all social media does is like
if people complicate it
don't understand how we work without
social media and then just or without
technology period
and then layer on technology and you'll
know how we act
like it's really that simple uh there's
it's
like the most attractive people in real
life are gonna get the most
most dates the most attractive people on
tinder are going to get the most dates
like it's not
it's not some complicated formula here
uh and then if you're a guy there's
going to be certain things that you're
going to have to add to your profile to
be more attractive
than than if you're a woman so it's
super interesting to me i think in
another life i would have been like an
online dating consultant or coach or
something
dude i could have seen you do that you
you see
so many uh men especially you see so
many men that it's like this is your
profile
no wonder you haven't met anyone like
why why one of the biggest
what are the biggest errors what are the
biggest mistakes that you think guys and
girls make when
setting up their profiles online yeah so
uh what the biggest mistake one is
set yourself up well first off figure
out what you're looking for
so if you want to look for a long-term
relationship uh and i'll just do it for
for guys i don't want to speak for a
woman but what you're going to want to
do is make yourself look like a
long-term attractive mate and
to be a long-term attractive mate
there's several different factors like
uh uh
and you not everyone's high in everyone
you can't be good looking and you can't
be kind and you can't be funny and you
can't be
i have a lot of resources yeah you need
a little bit of all of them
so what you've got to do is figure out
which one of these traits that you have
uh are most desirable and highlight
those traits
so again this goes back to the
evolutionary psychology thing
we're attracted to one people that are
good looking people always say beauty is
in the eye of the beholder
it's not really there there's some
cultural differences
but every culture likes good skin
good teeth good hair uh so there's
certain things so
that's why you have like these photoshop
apps that are so popular is because from
an evolutionary standpoint they make us
more
look more attractive because they make
us look more healthy because if you look
more healthy
you're going to have a higher chance of
reproducing with that person who's
healthy
and so you're going to want to make your
highlight your attractiveness as much as
possible and again it's why it's why if
you're a guy
you really like the best thing you can
do to be attractive is to lift weights
like just get fit like that that is
more than half of being attractive as a
guy and again it goes back to fitness it
goes back to evolutionary psychology
so one so do that so if you haven't
lifted weights lift weights
uh you know get a picture where your
teeth and hair and and uh and skin look
good
but then also but like that that's not
uh
it's not just that so you can't just be
good looking
if you want to be a long-term mate
you've also got to
uh really suggest that you're going to
be invested
in the long term in the long run and
you've also got to
show that you're going to be able to
access resources get resources provide
resources
so showing things like you're kind
showing things that maybe you have like
a bond with your family
uh you know that you're that you love
your mother kind of stuff you know and
that you would raise a kid who also
loves their mother
um and again i'm not saying to be
deceiving about this stuff i'm saying
it's marketing
highlight your best possible qualities
and you want to be trustworthy
and uh and you want and being things
like funny and intelligent
are important because those are ways to
get resources
you know people who are clever who work
hard who have ambition who are smart
tend to have more resources
so again if you can crack a joke right
away you can say something clever funny
or that it's the same reason why you
would put harvard on your tinder profile
you know it suggests that you're someone
of means that's gonna have more means
uh so you really want to do everything
to highlight your attractiveness
highlight your uh commitment to being a
long-term partner and
your ability to to gather resources
and this isn't to say that women need
resources or need someone to do it
but again i think we're all kind of
programmed we've all got this in our dna
that we're still attracted to that those
kind of people even if we don't need
it it's very difficult i think for
the vast majority of women to deprogram
the attraction to a man who has the
ability
to gather resources like it is
there are ladies out there who are the
breadwinners in the family that's
awesome
but the likelihood is if you are
richer or better educated
than the man that you are married to the
man is richer or more educated
than you are and or has some other
social notoriety incredibly talented
very muscular very good looking whatever
it is
because that's that's the way that life
has worked you are
battling against some deep
deep deep seated genetics if you are
able to work around that i had um
rob henderson on the show a couple of
months ago and
he he was a beast anyone that's
interested in this sort of evolution and
dating and how it rolls forward
should go back and check that episode
out but he taught me about the sexy sun
hypothesis
do you know about this oh it is uh
yes it's it's that let's see how much i
get right i'm going to butcher it yeah
but it's essentially that um
women are attracted to men who they
think would give them good-looking sons
because then they would be more likely
to reproduce as well yeah
precisely man you know yeah yeah uh-huh
the the evelyn it's just what's so funny
is that's why i love evolutionary
psychology so much it's like someone
says it it's just it just it clicks it
seems so logical
and you know someone comes up with a
better theory believe me i'll be the
first to
to get rid of it but like it's just
everything just kind of stacks up so
perfectly
what are some of the things that
i'll give you one of mine and then we'll
see if you can if you can give me some
of yours some of the kind of like
jaw drop moments when you read
evolutionary psychology one of mine
recently
has been learning about the purpose of
pride
that it's a positive feedback mechanism
for doing something which is challenging
and worthwhile
and that the sensation of pride is
something that we
intrinsically seek for ourselves as
someone who anyone who is an
entrepreneur
who goes and decides to train or do
anything that makes you feel
uncomfortable
you kind of seek the
endorphin hit after doing something but
it's all it was all abstract you've kind
of thought about it before and you know
how it fits into the bigger picture of
you in your life and
you can kind of get lost in the weeds
away from the fact that it's like
nah evolution's there for absolutely
everything that you do
and this is no different the sensation
of pride to me because it's something
uh continuing to motivate yourself most
of the motivation comes from
chasing that sense of pride that comes
afterward and you think like
well i'm not doing this for the hedonic
treadmill
i've done my explore i've ensured that
i've got rid of the trivial few and
focused on the
uh trivial many and focused on the vital
few and i'm
expressing my logos you know you've
taken the top one percent of
everyone's work that's looked at this
over the last few years
and you think that you understand why
you're doing something then evolution
just comes in
with a big sledgehammer and smashes you
in the face and goes yeah mate but it's
still just evolution
and the the thing about pride was a real
sort of
jaw drop moment for me yeah
well and also too and i'll answer your
question but pride with social media
it's so
it's so clear so it's like if you're
someone who's chasing uh that social
status
that to feel good about yourself think
about how social media
then plays into our evolutionary
predilections southern wordpress
elections whatever the way that we're
already designed
uh so i'm chasing this high of like
approval from other people and i'm
chasing like yeah i'm working out i'm
getting fit and i'm doing all this
and then i'm able to post a shirtless
picture of me on instagram
that then gets a thousand likes and you
can see how it's like this is all just a
big reward
of us doing this thing seeking social
status seeking pride
and uh like that's why social media has
totally
and i don't mean this in a in a try in
like a bad way
but you can see that social media has
like hijacked that or like
use it to their advantage like we and i
do it too
like everyone argues against seeking
yeah i there is absolutely a part of me
that likes having
uh you know however many followers on
twitter there's a part that likes me
getting
a thousand retweets i can say until the
cows come home i do it for myself i do
it to keep myself honest i do it
to to make sure that i'm increasing my
habits which sure that's true
and i could probably probably pass a lie
detector but again it's said identity
thing and i've got to get out of my own
head and get out who i am and it's like
you also like the fact that you've got
higher status now because you do it than
if you didn't do it
it's always uh to answer your question
though to answer your question
the one and we talked about it already
it's it's this gene thing
it's that we're not even in control of
the ship we're not the skipper
we're we are cargo like this what your
your brain all of it you if you've got a
gene that wants to get passed on
it is going to do whatever it takes to
get passed on because we think oh
evolution i get it like so i want to
reproduce i want to make another version
of me
and you're like no no it's even it's
deeper than that it's like
you've got this one little weird gene
that wants to make another version of
itself
and depending on how strong that gene is
compared to another gene
like that that's the stuff that's really
wild to wrap your head around
and and that's what makes you feel like
i'm not in control here i'm not i'm
you know like i'd like it's like uh it's
like you go on a ship
and uh there's like a little like a
steering wheel for the kids
to do like that's what life feels like
it's like oh i'm totally yeah
i'm like or when i was a kid i have a
little sister
and she'd want to play video games with
me and i didn't want her to play so i'd
give her a controller
and tell her she was playing like that's
that's where we are
there's no batteries in that controller
there's just batteries in the one that
i've got
and you and you think you're controlling
it and you're just as happy knowing it
but you're not controlling
anything have you read buddhism is true
by robert wright
why believe is true dude you would adore
it so imagine
yeah imagine the moral animal and then
adapt
the evolutionary psychology to why
meditation works and why eastern
philosophy has some truths to it
um highly recommended to anyone who's
listening if you if you fancy getting
into this
uh the audible version also is really is
quite easy listening i probably wouldn't
have wanted to audible
the moral animal i don't think i would
have enjoyed it as much i liked
rereading those mic drop moments
but yeah for why buddhism is true that's
good have you had look at much to do
with self-deception
uh no not really where are you going
just something on your mind yeah yeah
man that mustache
um no i i've just been blown away
with how convincing liars we are even to
ourselves
yeah yeah like that i don't i mean this
in the most
pernicious like source code
level of a way and this is one
this is one that really really shocked
me um
so couples that have been together
for a significant period of time
living together let's say maybe sort of
six
seven eight years who still haven't had
kids will tend to break up and there's
some
moderately robust stats that show this
that's presuming that they want to have
kids now
when you think why does this happen you
know everyone that's listening will have
had some friends perhaps you were one of
them
um that was in relationship for a real
long time you know
got together at university now we're
sort of 29 and
we've just grown apart i don't really
feel the same about them anymore our
interests don't really align and this
that and the other
you think not only is that perhaps what
you
told the other person but it's genuinely
what you felt or maybe you felt
some version some analog of that so you
were convinced
you yourself were convinced you could
pass a lie detector that was the reason
that you did it that's what you told
them that's what you told you that's
what your brain told you
however there is some pretty good
evidence
which shows that if you've been together
for a very very long time let's look
back to our
ancestral environment if you and another
person have been together for quite a
while
and there's still not been any kids
there's something wrong with one of you
that means it's beneficial for both of
you to go and be with someone else that
problem might be you
but that problem might be them and by
leaving and going to see if
the other person also has this problem
or perhaps if you've taken it along with
them
this is again presuming that most people
were trying to have children the
difference now is that people elect
not to have children but the genes don't
know and don't care
about that the genes don't care about
the fact that you're on the pill and
have been and
you just want to wait until you're 31
and then you're going to have
you're going to start to become a
baby-making mum
like that's they don't care about that
so
it would make sense for your genes to
say
something's up here that person and you
aren't a compatible match
because as of yet there's been no
children
but it wouldn't say to you that that's
not the best most effective way
what would happen is that you would
become more easily irritated about the
things that they did
the fact that they chew with the mouth
open perhaps isn't cute like they used
to anymore the fact that they make
little snoring noises in the night
isn't as endearing maybe just not as
attractive anymore
all of these different sort of the
parameters and the dials and the knobs
that
your genes can twist to change things
and then it tells you oh well you know
we're just kind of growing apart and
we're doing this that and the other
and then that's how it deploys so not
only are you convinced of that but your
genes have lied
made you lie to yourself about what's
going on and like upon reading that and
then
a hundred other examples of how you
don't really know your own motivations
at its deepest deepest level
you realize cargo in the ship is
exactly that the child that's just got
the toy wheel
and thinks that they know what's going
on and you can go
layers and layers and layers deep right
there's a there's a level of layers that
you could go back to consciously which
you need to strip where you discussed
about stripping away ego
and um becoming fully aware of why you
feel the way that you do and controlling
that
but then there's like another glass
ceiling to kind of try and get through
and up there that's where the real
that's where the real fat controller is
and he's up there with your genetics
twisting the knobs and moving the dials
blows my mind man absolutely and
it's why you it's so easy to see someone
else's motives
and then they tell you their motives and
it's completely different than what
you observed as an outsider but you know
for a fact that they could pass a lie
detector
it's like i know you believe this lie
because it's beneficial for you to
believe this lie and
it's and to you it's not a lie it's the
truth it goes back to this idea too that
like
we're all that we're all just again
cargo but imagine being cargo
that then when we arrive at our
destination we have to justify
how we got there while we got there so
so you get there and you're like so you
ended up
in you know in brazil and you're like
yeah that's where i wanted to go the
entire time
i was always going to brazil i love
brazil
rio is beautiful this time of year and i
love beaches
and you're like and but and again it's
it's you have to believe it
uh so yeah it's and again it goes back
to that jeans thing we got our genes
doing things that we are then
have to explain away and
again it's why it goes back to this ego
thing and it's so unbelievably hard it's
like i barely understand it that like
it's a thing
let alone can like do anything about it
but uh you know and and it's so hard to
see in yourself it's next to impossible
uh but it it's just like again we're
evolutionarily designed
to to decept ourselves you know it's a i
forget it's just saying something like
this like
the uh the way to tell a lie is to
believe it
and so and if you know it's a lie
you're not going to believe it but if
you honestly don't know it's a lie
then you're going to be just fine saying
that no we grew apart
that's why we got that's what's going on
i mean one of the things that came up
i think it's moral animal or why
buddhism is true uh this just sounds
like a robert wright
somewhere he's gonna be sat at home with
his [ __ ] ears burning
because me and you were just like
mouthing off about him for this entire
podcast
um yeah it was in one of those where
he spoke about the fact that our ability
to detect lies
as humans is really and deceit
deception is super high super super high
because the risk
previously would always have been
pretty vast it's one of the reasons why
we're the only primates who have
white around the outside of our eyes so
that we can see where each other's
looking
if you had dark eyes it would be more
difficult to see where you're looking
but
you've got white around the eyes which
means you can see eye contact tends to
be an indicator of truthfulness
and uh he was saying in that that
everybody else's ability to pick up on
our deception
means that we need to become incredibly
good liars and as you said
the best way to tell a convincing lie is
to believe it yourself
and to not even know that it's a lie
like
the fact that that is the as far as
one of the theories in uh why buddhism
is true is concerned
is the reason that we have consciousness
so the reason that we have consciousness
and central governor the ability to have
that like
executive function is to be the
narrative that plays the interim
between what our genes want and what our
actions are
like holy [ __ ] man like that's the sort
of thing that makes the hairs on the
back of your neck stand up
like the the fact that i'm able to step
into my own programming
or that i think that i can step into my
own programming
is the kid at the wheel again maybe the
kid at the wheel
analogy is that um
that daughter can move the ship by like
three percent
in either direction she has a minor
amount of control or maybe no less than
that
she can change the temperature of the
climate control and the station that the
radio is on
she can make some superficial changes
which do manifest
and make her feel like she's in control
but yet
yeah the the big [ __ ] that's going on
that's that's daddy daddy's daddy's
daddy sat up top and mom's got the map
out
like that's what's happening and then
the daughter is downstairs and she's
she's put the air conditioning on and
the radio's too loud yeah
she gets to pick whatever station she
wants to listen to that's that's that's
what we are
we're we're on a road trip and we have
no say in how fast we go
where we go when we get there but we can
listen
to 90s grunge if we want to that's what
we get
especially as well as you're on this
kind of
wisdom-seeking journey which i i have to
say i really love
like the last sort of five years this
pivot
say what you want about him but people
like sam harris jordan peterson
uh ben shapiro brett weinstein eric
weinstein joe rogan
um the fact that you have smart minds
teaching you how to step into your own
programming or at least alerting you to
the fact that it's possible to do that
is something that i don't think we've
had at least not on mass
ever before you know you can read seneca
or marcus aurelius's meditations but
you need you basically need to read
those with a companion book which is the
person that tells you how it works
right and that's what some of the best
content creators and podcasters and
video
and writers from the last few years have
done they've synthesized
stuff that's quite abstract quite
difficult to to work out what's going on
and giving it to people and this kind of
wisdom sphere whatever you want to call
it
i love i think it's amazing people like
naval who are obviously like the
synthesis
like they're the pharmaceutical weapons
grade plutonium
version of like this wisdom sphere um
the fact that you have that
at your fingertips is amazing and
what is scary to realize is that that's
kind of pushing the limit
of trying to break social norms as best
you can
to be in design of your own life to be
in control of the direction that you
take
and yet with all of this liberation all
of this information the best minds on
the planet giving you some of the best
advice they can sometimes distill down
into a 360 character tweet
like you're still just cargo in the ship
or the the daughter downstairs
air conditioning [ __ ] sake
the at least the best part about it is
like
being able to see it you know when like
when you turn on the media and you see
what they're doing to you
and you pay attention to political
debate you see how they're just going
after emotional responses and
like at least you can kind of choose not
to participate in some of the things
that are unhealthy for you
um again you're you know maybe it's like
you get a little maybe you start with uh
controlling the
the volume and then they give you the
air conditioner then you can roll down
the window
uh you know it's like the more you do
you get at least a little more say
and that's why um i think knowing these
things is so important
it's like it just even if it's one
percent better it just has such a huge
impact over the course of your life
what are some of the lessons that you
wish that you'd known
sort of 5 10 15 years ago anything that
comes to mind like that
i wish i would have gone a lot deeper on
this topic in general
a long time ago so i started probably
when i was in college to like
uh be interested in this and i've always
kind of and it started with a i had an
amazing professor
opened my eyes was a behavioral consumer
i think consumer behavior class or
something like that
but he didn't teach any he didn't teach
anything about marketing it was
literally about like here's how we're
programmed here's how we're hardwired
and you have to be able to sell yourself
before you can even sell a product so
learn how we operate and so ever since
then it was uh it's been bouncing around
in my head
and he actually i still have that i
might even have the textbook right here
i just moved and i kept it out
um but it's something i like i'd kind of
revisit every few years
but i wasn't nearly as diligent about it
and i didn't
really go as deep as i could have uh so
i wish i would have gone real deep into
that and i wish i would have uh
found like-minded people early on to
kind of have those conversations to
to sit and you know think about that
stuff as opposed to
uh you know whatever like you end up
being friends with the people you're
around
uh and i've i've actually got a friend
in my house right now who might be
listening and i don't mean you
friend like we're good but you know
like you're you're a product of your
circumstances like think about some of
your best friends
often are the people that were in the
same hallway
the same floor of you as your dorm when
you went to college like
so much of your life is by chance i i
met my significant other
on tinder and had i not swiped right now
she not swiped right
uh it would have been complete you know
which by the way is just chance like
and obviously we were able to filter
through and uh uh realize that we both
liked what we brought to the table and
it all worked out
um but to not leave some of that stuff
up by chance
you know to to search out like-minded
people and to search out people who want
to have these conversations and to think
about these things
uh i would i would have pursued that a
lot earlier and a lot more and
especially in a college atmosphere like
ideally there's a lot of those people i
i think it might be less and less true
now i might be
um you know a little nostalgic for a
time that that no longer
might be maybe lips as well yeah right
right right we might be looking back at
the 60s when we're like yeah they were
revolutions and yeah maybe they were
smoking a bunch of pop but they were
having these philosophical conversations
and maybe when we go back there it's
really just
now they were just partying the whole
time and dancing the music and it's and
it's no different
so i wish i would have and i you know i
feel a bit like i'm making up for lost
time it's i've
been able to i mean honestly doing this
podcast is an extension of that
uh reaching out to people on twitter is
has been such a godsend
so if anyone wants to do this anyone's
listening to this going god i feel like
i'm behind that's why i love twitter so
much there's so many people talking
about this there's so many people
thinking about it
and that you can connect to any of them
at any time
it's just so powerful so i'm such a fan
of twitter for that reason and
and uh and it facilitates like i see the
value in longer conversations
like this like we could never do this
via twitter even if we're in the dms it
just doesn't happen
but twitter facilitates a twitter can be
the gateway
to stuff like this and so i just think
it's so powerful
you're right man as well it's a good
point to bring up there to say that if
you're not
if you haven't decided to delve deep
into reading evolutionary psychology or
the basis for human emotion or you
haven't started meditating
like it really it doesn't matter like i
was
i'm pretty much certain that under the
age of 25
none of this stuff would be able to have
much of an impact in any case because
the context in which you are
consuming it is so chaotic and
changeable
like there's still the vast majority of
[ __ ] that you do is new
you know you go out you have a
conversation with someone it's the first
time you've ever had that conversation
before
i think yeah the ability to look at
stuff with finer grain
is when the ship is so big that it
starts to steady itself on the waves a
little bit
it's like if you're constantly flipping
from one from starboard to port
all the time every single oh my god now
i've got a girlfriend i've never had a
girlfriend before i don't really know
what to do
oh my god now we've split up i don't
really know i'm on holiday i'm here i'm
on a plane i'm doing this
it's like dude just live live in that
moment and
this was a realization that i came
across
from a luke combs song while i was in
america last year doing a road trip
it's the first line of this song and he
says at 17 you don't think that much
about life
you just live it i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's it man
like that that is the reason that time
seemed to expand and dilate when you
were younger and seems to get quicker
when you are older
like 24 hours today is the same amount
of time as you had 24 hours 10 years ago
and 20 years ago in the day that you
were born
but the lack of a learner's mind the
lack of new and novel experiences
the lack of presence is what's causing
time to speed up
what people say when they say i need
more time or time's going so quickly
is i need more memories because memories
are like
individual slots they're like little
cuts in the cake
that identify how many pieces
you've gone through in that time and if
you're spending
every day doing the night five driving
to work the same route to work the same
conversation the same netflix and
and doritos on an evening time like why
would your brain
make memories from that like if you want
to if you want to make memories make
something be worthwhile of being
memorable
and um it's
again it's that the sort of beauty of
getting older is that you can
increase the resolution of what how you
look at things
to make stuff new you have this wider
context you have all of these different
examples and then you can start to look
at stuff with a little bit more uh
dexterity right a little bit finer grain
and you go [ __ ] like that's cool i
didn't think that i didn't think that
would have been cool before and you can
compare it to you 10 years ago and go
10 years ago me would have been
embarrassed about this but me now thinks
this is awesome
uh to your point too about making
memories and stuff
uh fully and and like totally you get
stuck in a routine and you just realize
like did i just waste a year after work
and you know
woke up drove went to work came back
home turned on netflix had dinner went
to bed
uh so what we're doing is i'm in a place
in atlanta right now
we've rented it out we're just gonna
drive across the country for
five six months and just stay in
different cities
a few weeks at a time where you're so
taken out of your routine that you can't
help but make memories you can't help
but build memories
uh to do a lot of stuff to do as much
stuff possible as outdoors
to experience like just all these new
things and and again like this is kind
of a blessing of the current situation
uh is to take something that is a
negative
and to figure out like how can i uh i
shouldn't
even say well it's definitely negative
but take a take a new kind of uh
scenario that you're in
and you kind of think how do i turn this
to my advantage
and so the fact that we don't have to be
in an office the fact that we don't have
to be in any particular city
we're using that to our advantage to go
explore cities
and to go explore nature like we're
going to drive up through yellowstone
we're going to drive up through like
some of the most beautiful parts
of the united states and park there and
work for a month or whatever it might be
and that's something like i'm going to
remember that i'm very confident i will
remember that
so so yeah totally on board and it is
it's
it's hard though we gotta unprogram our
monkey brains of like being able to even
enjoy it
and it's so easy to get back in like
these comfortable habits
and uh one thing that you were talking
about and i thought of when you were
talking about kind of this buddhism
buddhism and
eastern philosophy part of me feels like
the reason that some of the stuff
matters and exists and even resonates
now it's almost like we're
we're trying to find solutions to the
fact that we live in a world now that
we're no longer designed for
so obviously like we're not designed to
live in society we're not like all this
we're not designed for agriculture we're
not designed to live in houses like this
we were designed
to kind of be in small groups and to
travel and uh
and honestly we're not designed to work
eight hours a day ten hours a day
whatever it is we were designed to work
like
two or three hunt something gather
something maybe make a fire maybe maybe
make some shelter
and then relax for most of the day like
that's when we're most productive but
then all of a sudden we invented
agriculture you gotta tend to the crops
all day
and then there's industry and so now
we're stuck and there's no way evolution
can keep up with that so we've hacked
our own brains i think that to me is
honestly what
what these ways of living are is how do
we take the society that we made
that is not ideal for our uh for our
systems
and make it so that we're able to live
in this environment that there's no way
we're designed for this
it's interesting you brought that up
shane parish farnam street has a quote
where he says uh
tradition is a set of problems a set of
solutions for which we have forgotten
the problems
it's like these questions that have been
asked i had a
alex o'connor cosmic skeptic on the
other day talking and teaching us about
ethics what ethics is
and he was giving us some of the
classical ethical
um thought experiments that you can do
like would you push a fat man onto the
bridge to stop the train from hitting
five people
what if it was three people what if it
was one person but it was a baby and
blah blah blah
and um he was saying so much of this
stuff
is just brought from classic texts
and then re repurposed these are the
fundamental questions that people have
been asking since the beginning of time
since the beginning of
working out what morality is what ethics
are how to lead a good life
what it means to be a good person and to
live well
do you think those questions it hasn't
do you think those questions started
so let's say just to make things easy
let's say that we've been who we are
uh you know dna wise for a hundred
thousand years okay and let's say that
uh society has existed for ten thousand
years okay like
agriculture roughly starts around then
uh have we had those questions for 10
000 years
or 100 000 years
that's a really good question
there's an interesting thing
to do with the maslow's hierarchy of
needs
and i think that one of the challenges
we have
the existential crisis that people
sometimes come up against and the
melancholy and the feelings of
hopelessness and meaninglessness and the
increase in suicide that we see in the
modern world
i think a big part of that may be due to
the fact
that the bottom levels of that pyramid
are very well looked after
that if all that you want from life
is to not freeze to death and to find
some berries today
it's very easy to get a positive
feedback mechanism from that so if it's
100 000 years ago and you're living
somewhere that's real
cold in the winter surviving winter is
like
actualizing that is you you've reached
the peak of what you wanted to do
whereas now when you can uber michelin
star food
from around the corner to your house
while you watch netflix on your
amazon all of you clothes that you need
and
you do whatever else like airbnb
yourself a holiday like
the convenience is so high those answers
those questions have been answered which
means that the things further up which
are more
existential more melancholy more
abstract they require higher levels of
complexity and sophistication to even
think about what's happening
you have to do self-development work to
get to the top
of that pyramid for the most part unless
you end up having to be
uh lining up with a life which is
perfectly aligned with your values which
tends to be quite
rare it seems you're gonna have these
challenges like you're going to come up
against stuff that makes you think like
why am i here what am i doing with my
life
but if avoiding a saber-toothed tiger
or like i i i managed to make a new
spear today
like if that's actualization for you
then it's a little bit it's
bizarrely almost easier to feel to reach
the top of it so
i think that some of the more
existential questions that we've come up
against about what it means to lead a
good life
i think that the luxury questions
they're questions that can only be asked
in a time
of abundance rather than scarcity i'm
aware that there's still been serious
times of scarcity throughout the last 10
000 years but significantly less as soon
as you've got
agriculture and you can trade and you've
got security and you're living in bigger
groups
those questions come to the forefront
because previously they would have never
had to have been asked
right and maybe this is all just a
manifestation
of neurose because we live in societies
anyways
you know it's like we've got you know
when you
put everyone in a city you've got new
problems you got more conflict you got
strangers that you don't recognize and
so we've got all these
modern anxieties or whatever it might be
that
are uh a product of this like
yeah it's more complicated but maybe
maybe it should be simpler like why
we're inventing
we're inventing problems that don't have
to necessarily exist
like why wouldn't i love to make a spear
and
nap for most of the day under under a
sun under a tree
uh and you're obviously you are still
finding mates you are still finding love
like love is a hundred
hundred thousand years old uh or at
least the sensation of it
and uh like uh sounds pretty good well
look the problem is you need the
you need everyone to jump into everybody
get on board right
yeah everyone literally everyone has to
be on board we're two we're way past
that we can't go back to it so that's
why you got to figure out like the
self-actualization
techniques to to make do with the
society that we're in you know the hand
that you're dealt
well think about diogenes right one of
the first
cynics he was living in a pot
which he was like literally living in
the thing that people used to urinate in
and yet he was this is two and a half
thousand years ago
and he was talking about casting off
possessions
that living simply is the key to a happy
life
there's this story where alexander the
great uh went to go meet him
and said um diogenes if i should not be
alexander i would wish to be you
and he basically replied and said yes
i'm not surprised
um he said is there anything i i command
half of the world is there anything that
you would want
he replied and said yes for you to get
out of my son
and you think like when you have someone
back then there's the level of abundance
present in ancient athens was nowhere
near as much as we have now
and yet you still have philosophers and
people who are talking about
casting off possessions casting off
desires stripping themselves back the
ascetic lifestyle and look at what we're
seeing now
in the modern era the minimalist
movement we're seeing people who are
living
living lives with 40 possessions
and in apartments that are a couple of
hundred square feet
and you know this van life thing
this van life which is like i guess
you're like the glamping version of van
life at the moment where you've got i am
we're staying in the airbnb's i'm
getting a fresh shower i'm
i i talk a big game but i'm not living
my band
i'm going to accustom to certain things
yeah man like pooping in a toilet but
yeah
that's a big one for me maybe maybe one
of them i have a bidet and i'll get
lucky
that would be really good um but yeah
dude i i think
i don't know man it would be interesting
if everyone was able to cast it off
and i think everyone asks themselves
this question
a little bit you know you look at a dog
anyone who's ever spent a lot of time
looking at a dog and
getting pure joy from one will have
looked at it and thought [ __ ] it would
be so easy to be that dog
like to be my dog i would not have to
have a concern
i would be loved i would be fed i would
be watered
the question of whether or not that's an
option
i don't know i genuinely don't
you would have to be incredibly ballsy
to say look this is my commitment
i know the things that make me happy in
life
um but i definitely think that
if we look to the people that are older
than us as
examples of an evolution of lifestyle
and or
ideas that show where where
our projection our um trajectory
is likely to go most people
end up leading a simpler life as they
get older than when they were younger
it's like you have a state of disorder
going to order
right you have like this kind of bizarre
entropy thing going on
but within people's lifestyle design you
know you look at the danville's area
into this world or anyone that's 18
you're excited by everything and rightly
so
but look at your grandad that's
70 years old 75 years old he's just
happy
going to watch the football on the
saturday afternoon chilling out reading
his book doing this that any other
like what does that tell us that tells
us probably that given all of the
choices of things within the world
there are a few simple pleasures that
people will tend toward
and i wonder i wonder how much
we can shortcut our own path to get
there
by using people that are older than us
and have allowed this evolution this a b
split testing of lifestyles
to say well maybe maybe i tried that a
little bit sooner
maybe i'll try and get there a little
bit earlier
it's it's probably easier said than done
it's almost it reminds me of something
i think jim jim carrey has this quote
something along the lines of like i wish
everyone could be a millionaire
because they would so that they would
realize it's not the answer to anything
and it con is the same thing it's like
you don't think
sitting on the porch and having a cup of
coffee in the morning
is going to be like the best there ever
is you're like no i've got to go travel
and i've got it you have this experience
that
experience
again go to vegas do whatever and then
once you do it it's like you have to
have
the the comparison you have to know that
like was it actually really that great
you know what's nice is just being
peaceful here
just sitting and enjoying this moment
with someone that i enjoy talking to or
even
solitude in yourself and so
i don't know that there is a shortcut to
it the 70 year old does it because the
70 year old did the other [ __ ]
and was like this is too much of a
hassle this isn't enjoyable this is what
i love i you know i like this football
team
i like watching it or i like drinking
sweet tea on the porch at sunset
and you realize like that's what
happiness is about and that's why
uh you know it's not about getting a
bunch of stuff like at the end of the
day like
anything behind me could disappear
tomorrow and if you're attached to that
stuff it's it's
bringing you the wrong kind of happiness
it's not happiness anyways well look at
what elon musk said on joe rogan
joe was like so elon why are you selling
all of your possessions he says because
it's an attack vector
and he's right an attachment to anything
is a weakness because that thing can be
taken away from you now there's certain
things that you don't want to not be
attached to like your family and the
people that you love and your friends
and the passions that you have in life
and the interests and so on and so forth
there is probably a million caveats that
i'm going to get criticized about for
that like evolution of ideas just do
what old people do basically like let's
all just be old-age pensioners at the
mid-20s yeah but one of them one of them
is a naval quote it is easy to fulfill
your material desires than to renounce
them
it's like significantly easier to go and
buy a 10 year old beat up truck
after your last car was a ferrari than
to go through life wondering what it's
like to drive a ferrari
and i i part of it is going to be a
selection bias
for the fact that those people might
have completed a bunch of the stuff that
they've done
so i had aubrey marcus on the show about
a year ago and he said i was like
so what what is a good life to you and
he said like to live you know to do the
things
like to take the drugs not all of the
drugs to have the experiences to go to
the places to make love to laugh to
see these things to build the business
to fail at building the business you
know like all of the different things
because that is what life is
um i don't know how much of that you can
shortcut
and i don't know how much of that you
could just cast off and say well i don't
choose to do this you know anyone that's
ever
worked on a project that they really
don't like you know like oh there's just
been a bit of a grind and you're there
again
and you're like why am i doing this to
myself like i could just
go outside and just have a cup of sweet
tea and look at the night sky
and i'd be perfectly happy have i
ratcheted up
the level of complexity that my life is
required to fulfill to a point which is
so unbelievably chaotic that
basically i've detached myself away from
the vast majority of stuff that would
have truly made me happy
um and in a society of abundance like
we've got now
hypernormal stimuli from our mobile
devices and
the artificial light that we've got
which is playing around with our
circadian rhythm and
diets that are misaligned to us and
living for longer like living for
so much longer than we've ever lived
before like
i don't know man i don't know yeah it's
it's for the most part well this is what
i love too is like so many of these uh
problems that we have there's old
solutions to them that's why again we'll
just go back to evolutionary psychology
because apparently this is like a
fanboy conversation of psych but
you look like you're not feeling well
you're feeling overweight you're feeling
lethargic like look at your diet
what did people use to eat like they
these are all
modern uh ailments uh again like you're
feeling sleepy you're feeling
uh like you don't have enough energy
what are you doing physically
like are you mimicking what what they
were doing what are you doing for your
sleep
like so many of these problems uh can be
solved with with this ancient wisdom or
this just really what
comes natural to us and and we've got to
like sometimes you gotta shake yourself
out of it and again i'm just as guilty
of it as the next person there's plenty
of times where i get lost on twitter at
you know
10 p.m at night trying to go to bed uh i
justify it because i say it's for my job
but
but still it's uh you know there's all
these
like the secret to me or like if anyone
asks like what's the secret to life it's
think about about you know 15 000 years
ago how people would have lived and just
try to mimic that as much as possible
and it's again it's easier said than
done and we live in a different society
where you need money you need resources
you need these things to survive and get
by
um but just kind of know where your uh
uh
like what your end objective is into
getting this stuff you know
and and maybe and to your point about
the ferrari some people just need to get
the ferrari
just to know that like all right i did
it and i'm you know
like i don't have that yearning anymore
and i scratch that itch
and i don't need another ferrari and you
know it brought me a moment of happiness
or even a year of happiness but
after a while it's just your car you
know it's just
it's just something that sits in your
garage i love it man
i think that's a good point to end there
dude i really enjoyed this so
people want to check out your stuff
where should they go
super easy go on instagram go on twitter
m-k-o-b-a-c-h
that's m kobach um yeah follow along
um i've got a new job that i'm super
excited about
yeah certainly no no it's a it's a tech
startup it's called fast
and uh the reason i joined is one i
wanted to get into the startup life
it's kind of the same idea it's like you
wanna um you know you wanna try new
things like i have this itch it's the
same kind of ferrari thing
like i wanted to join a startup and help
build something and if it succeeds
i'm unbelievably happy and if it fails i
still get to say hey i tried to do this
new thing
and i got to be part of this
their goal is to make everything that
you hate filling out on the internet
only one click
so anytime you want to buy something you
don't have to fill out your credit card
your email
your name all that stuff it already
knows who you are and you just click
buy it anytime that you need to identify
like the bigger pictures anytime you
need to identify who you are on the
internet
as long as the that website has their uh
api in it you will be able to just click
that one button
you're done so you can think like uh you
know i'm not gonna give away any secrets
or anything
but literally anything you ever do
online that you need to prove who you
are and i'm not talking social security
number but like literally ordering
something online you need to prove who
you are
uh that they would then be the one stop
shop for all that information
that's cool it's like a uh a passport
like a digital passport online
where it automatically just shows it and
the website lets you through
and does the thing [ __ ] man i need
amazon amazon
think about how much time yeah think
about how much time you waste filling
out forms
online how many times you would have
bought something online and you're like
eh
i don't feel like filling this out never
mind i can't check out as a guest i'm
not doing that on that website
because it's too much of an awesome for
me to enter my emails and sign up to
their newsletter
yep and imagine and you can see like
yeah you can imagine it for newsletters
you can imagine little and it's not just
payments but it's anything you need to
log into
uh you would you would do so many
different things if all you had to do
was collect and you're in
i like it myself that's cool and i'm
gonna guess you'd be able to integrate
that with password managers and all
sorts of other stuff
so that it would be like that's the
dream man a seamless world where i don't
have to fill forms in [ __ ] out
can you hurry up again hurry up and get
off holiday and get this
start up moving please so that i i don't
have to fill forms in anything
don't i've already started we're we're
we're doing it man it's it's
launching but it's just the reason you
joined too it's such this pain
point that everyone gets and if you
think about it the internet's like
buying stuff online is 30 years old
and it hasn't changed it hasn't updated
once it is such a hassle of the process
and it should be so much better and so
we're hoping to make it better so i love
it
fingers crossed i love it you ever see
the button you just you just gotta
promise me you click it if you ever see
the button it's just fast it's black
you'll you'll you'll recognize it you'll
click it you'll get my practice
again don't you worry you will get my
click throughs dude thank you so much
for your time matthew everyone
uh that is listening if you enjoyed this
episode go and give matthew a follow
online let me know what you thought as
well if any of the comments about
buddhism or your child driving the
the spaceship if any of that stuff
resonated you know where to get me at
chris
will x where if you follow me like share
and subscribe and all that good stuff
for now matthew thanks man thank you
loved it
had a great time
you